se trata de una vigilia de navidad sin
precedentes en la historia reciente del
cristianismo este año a causa del
coronavirus la tradicional misa de gallo
ha sido adelantada años atrás esta misa
se llevaba a cabo a medianoche pero este
jueves el papá francisco dio inicio a
esta celebración a las siete y treinta
de la noche hora de roma para permitir a
las personas presentes lograr regresar a
sus hogares antes del inicio del toque
de queda impuesto por el gobierno
italiano a partir de las 10 de la noche
hora de roma la misa el papá francisco
se llevó a cabo en la basílica de san
pedro en el vaticano que pueden ver aquí
detrás mío estuvo enmarcada por un
estricto protocolo de seguridad
sanitaria poquísimas personas estuvieron
presentes son un centenar de personas
pudieron entrar mientras que el año
pasado más de siete mil fieles católicos
acompañaron al papá francisco durante
esta ocasión este jueves durante su
homilía el papá francisco evocó el
sentido profundo de lo que es la navidad
el contexto de extrema
en el cual se dio el nacimiento del niño
jesús y exhortó a los fieles católicos a
vivir estas fiestas lejos del espíritu
del consumismo y tratando de ayudar a
los más necesitados